Start recording.
Welcome, everybody.
Another League of Legends AMA Entrepreneurship
featuring me and Rishy Cup TV.
Hey, good morning, everybody.
Happy Wednesday.
Happy Wednesday, 9 a.m. Eastern.
Ready to go.
Me and Rishy Cup TV, I like it.
I love it.
I like it.
All right, queuing up.
Hopefully I get my Teemo jungle.
We can go along here and
let's get into the first question.
What do we got, Rishy?
We're gonna help answer some questions.
Well, first of all, what's in the cup?
I feel like we haven't been good
on that tradition of what's in the cup.
Well, today, I have a coffee from Chick-fil-A,
but beyond what is literally in my coffee cup,
I have a cup of excitement
to add massive value to entrepreneurs today.
I love it, I love it.
I'm in a Fitbit competition again,
so I'm stepping while I'm playing and answering questions.
Fabulous.
Are you drinking your protein drink today?
I do, we got it here,
but I have to drink my vitamins first
because Nina says I have to drink this on an empty stomach
or she gets upset at me, so.
We love Nina.
We do love Nina.
All right, let's get into it.
Question time.
I'm excited.
Yeah, me too.
First question comes from Jeremy.
Jeremy is a young entrepreneur, 20 years old,
and he has just a little bit of advice about his time
because he currently is working full-time
in a collections office,
but his real dream is to start a clothing business,
a clothing line.
Okay.
But what happens is he works so hard
when he goes to his day job
that when he gets home, he's exhausted
and he's just not sure what he should do
because he's not finding that he has time
to actually work on his passion,
which is his clothing line.
So my, thanks for the question, Jeremy.
I think feeling like you have a lack of time
is definitely common amongst anyone
who wants to pursue their dream.
And I think that the first thing
is to look at your situation,
and the good news is that you have a job,
that you have the ability to be making money
because maybe right now that's teaching you skills
that you may need for your business,
but also being able to make money
that you could be thinking about saving
to invest into this clothing line.
That's the good news.
You know, your job could be a means
to getting to this clothing line.
But I think the biggest,
it can kind of be an excuse that we tell ourselves
that we don't have enough time
because at the end of the day,
you have limited time,
but I believe that we all have limited time
and we all have to learn how to use
the limited time that we have.
So to make it really practical for you,
I'd be asking yourself,
what's something you can do daily
that is a non-negotiable time
that you could spend every day on your business?
And I think even it might feel like
you're not getting a lot done,
even if it's that 30 minutes right after you eat dinner,
you know, before you go to bed
to get up and grind the next day,
that 30 minutes just committing to it non-negotiable,
and that little amount can lead to good results
if you're consistent with it.
So I think it's kind of a lie that we don't have enough time.
I think there's always a way to make time for what you love.
What do you think, sir?
Yeah, over to me.
All right, cool.
Yeah, a couple things.
One, in agreeing with Rishy, you never had the time.
It's like, when is the right time to have a baby?
Well, there's never the right time,
but you have to look after that baby, right?
And when it's crying at three in the morning,
you gotta get up and look after that baby.
And so your business is your baby too,
and you're not looking after it,
and you need to make the time to be able to look after it,
whether it is like, I'd like the half an hour a day idea,
whether that's at a certain time,
like whether you wake up half an hour earlier,
or whether you're staying up half an hour late,
whatever it is, to make sure that there's progress.
The other thing I would say though,
is I would try to find a job where I'm learning
about the industry that I wanna get into,
because you can learn so much by doing it yourself,
and hustling, and researching,
and that half an hour a day you'll learn,
but you'll learn a lot more when you're being mentored,
and when you can spend a lot more time on it.
And so if your job was in collections,
is that what it was?
Jeremy's job was in collections?
Exactly.
Right.
So he's not learning much about the clothing business
by being in collections, apart from I guess,
how to make people pay when they don't pay you.
There's some kind of skill to learn there,
but otherwise, yeah, you're not gonna be making money,
you're not gonna be learning about
how to make money in that industry.
So what I'd suggest is go find a job in the business
where you can learn, not in some huge company,
but in a smaller company where you can learn
from the CEO founder.
I usually like to look for companies
that are about 10 employees or less,
someone who's established, but not yet so big
that your job will just be fetching coffee
and really mean your work.
And get to know them, and learn from them,
and be inspired by them, and take on more projects,
and volunteer to be involved more often
in the things that they're doing.
Because you'll learn about the industry,
and you'll learn to make connections,
and you'll make mistakes while getting paid to do it,
instead of making all those mistakes on your own.
And so the reason to get a job is to learn.
And so if you're having a hard time
in your collections industry and trying to figure out
how to make more time for your business
and pursue your passion, then yes,
I agree with setting half an hour a day,
even if you're exhausted, to go and work it.
But then also, I'd be looking at switching my job
so that I'm learning, because that's gonna really
multiply your efforts and get you there a lot faster.
Nice.
Now Evan, sorry, really quickly,
we've got some people wanting to watch the stream
and they're not seeing you live.
I'm not seeing you live, but I thought it was just on my end.
Yeah, I saw that too, I don't know.
It says I'm streaming and it's recording,
so at least we'll be able to upload it to YouTube.
I don't know what's going on with Twitch today.
Gotcha, okay.
Yeah, a job in working with another fashion designer
sounds a lot more exciting than working in collections.
For him, right?
Yeah.
A person who wants to start a collection business
should learn about the collections industry first.
So if you're not learning from your job,
for any of you who are watching who have a job
and you're not liking it, as soon as you stop learning
at your job, it's time to move on.
It doesn't mean you have to start your own business yet,
you may not be ready, you may not have the financial
resources, you may not have the knowledge, experience,
be able to provide the value, all that stuff,
but if you're not learning at your job anymore,
then you're just wasting time.
You gotta go do something that at least you're learning
new things about, and that meaning you bounce
from a couple jobs until you find the one
that you're really learning, makes you come alive.
Great, hope that helps you Jeremy.
Good luck.
Next question comes from Nathan.
Nathan says, he's at the very beginning stages
of being an entrepreneur, he's looking for a job,
and so it kind of sounds like he's in the same situation
a little bit with Jeremy, trying to get a job
that will give him some skills in his ultimate dream
of being an entrepreneur.
He says he thought that telemarketing would be a good fit
for him when he was thinking about some of his strengths,
but later he felt like the telemarketing jobs were,
in his own words, going to kill his character.
He thought it may be a little dishonest, stressful,
so he's wanting just general advice about what he should do
as he looks for a job as an aspiring entrepreneur.
Okay, so Nathan, I think, I definitely don't think
that all telemarketing jobs necessarily require
that you have to be dishonest or that
I think the main thing about telemarketing jobs
is finding a company and a product that you actually feel
you believe in and that will give value to your customers,
because obviously you do have to be someone
who's going to successfully sell that product,
and so the way to not feel dishonest
is to actually be selling something you think
will really help people, and I think that would take away
a lot of the feelings of dishonesty.
So it sounds like your strengths are maybe,
you're maybe you're interested in sales,
maybe the dealing with people, interpersonal skills
was something that was attractive to you about that,
so if it's something that you think
you still really want to pursue,
I would say try to find a company and a product
that you actually really believe in,
and I think that will take care of the feeling
that it would kill your character.
Aside from that, though, I want to know more
about your actual business, because I then would be able
to give you a little bit better feedback
in regards to maybe some alternatives.
I mean, telemarketing may not be the best fit.
I know for me in general, like if I'm looking for jobs,
I definitely want to be in a place that is going
to bring out my strengths or help me
make my strengths even stronger.
So maybe telemarketing isn't actually the best fit,
but maybe there are other ways
that you can be involved in sales,
or being involved with dealing with learning
how to communicate with customers
that will then give you some of the skills
that you want to bring to your business later on.
I like it.
Yeah, what are you passionate about?
What are you passionate about, Nathan?
I'd love to hear more about what really gets you excited.
What do you think, Evan?
I like it.
I got my Timo jungle on, so it's a good start.
Yeah. It's a good start.
Yes.
This was Nathan?
This is Nathan.
Nathan.
Yeah, so one, I guess, for everybody writing,
I was going to say Colin, everybody writing in,
yeah, a little bit more context helps
when you're presenting a challenge
to know the situation a little bit more.
It doesn't mean you have to write 10-page long life story,
because that usually gets ignored,
but what kind of business do you want to start
would be pretty helpful.
I'm assuming that you want to get into telemarketing
because you want to learn how to sell,
because in whatever business you're going to get into,
you're going to have to learn how to sell.
I would say, unless you want to start
a telemarketing company,
don't go work at a telemarketing company.
Similar to Jeremy, the last one,
I would say look at a company that has 10 employees or less
in the industry that you want to start.
If you wanted to start in the fashion business,
you might say, well, I want to learn how to sell,
so I'm going to get a telemarketing job,
and that's going to teach me the skills,
and then I can move on.
What I love about Nathan's approach is that
he's trying to get a job where he can learn
so that he can start the business,
so it's not just earning a paycheck,
but he's going to learn something that will help him.
The thing is, if you want to learn how to sell clothes,
it may not be the best start
to go to a telemarketing company.
If you are going to go work, intern, volunteer, whatever,
at a fashion company right now,
they're going to sell.
How do they sell their stuff right now,
and how can you be on the sales team and learn from them?
Are they using a telemarketing company?
Maybe, but probably not.
So you want to be looking at the ideal company
that you want to build.
That 10-person company where you say,
I could see myself being like this person
in a couple years, that's my aspiration and my goal,
then that's where you should be looking for a job.
That's where you want to go and learn from,
and again, take on as much responsibility,
get as close to the CEO founder as possible, learn.
Most people at a job do just enough
so that they don't get fired.
And so when you come in and you are working hard
and hustling and wanting to get involved in more projects
and coming up with ideas,
you're just going to naturally rise up.
People will notice you,
and especially in a small 10-person company,
you're going to get more responsibility.
So even if you start at the bottom,
then you got to build your way up pretty quickly
just by showing your passion and your hustle.
And so I think that's going to be the best opportunity
for you as opposed to working in a telemarketing job.
And in general, anything that you feel is soul-sucking,
don't do it.
You have limited time.
You can do a lot of different things with your talents,
and life is not worth spending it on things
and on people that bring us down.
Yeah, that's great.
I hope that, Nathan, you can find something
that really is in line with what your passion is
and let us know what your passion is.
All righty.
Next question comes from Jameel.
Jameel says he's 47 years old,
and for most of his career,
he's been working in the food industry
because his father,
that was something that his father really wanted for him.
And his father probably had a lot of problems
with his food industry.
And his father passed away in 2009,
and that's when he discovered,
or actually about four years ago,
he says he discovered that his real passion
is video editing.
All right.
So now he wants to make a change.
He wants to specialize in making movies
for kids' birthday parties and graduations,
that sort of thing.
And he's kind of stuck because he's asking,
should I follow my passion,
or should I follow what I know
and what I know can be easy money,
which is the food industry.
He's got 24 years of experience there.
And yeah, so he's just kind of,
I think he's torn between the fact
that he has to pay his bills and can do it with the food,
but really wants to be doing the filming
and the editing of parties and graduations and whatnot.
So thanks to Mel for the question.
This is definitely a common struggle.
You have your responsibilities financially,
but you also want to pursue
the thing that makes you come alive.
So I think for sure,
I'm a believer in absolutely going after
the thing that makes you come alive.
We've just, the last two questions
just kind of talked about not getting,
you know, not giving all your time to things
that aren't going to be making you really come alive.
The food, you know, I don't know if you hate doing food
or if it's something that you actually do enjoy somewhat,
because I think one thing you could do is,
you don't necessarily have to completely stop
doing food right away, you know,
and completely, you know, cut off your source of income
just to pursue this video editing passion.
But can you find a way right now to, you know,
transition so that you can still be making videos,
getting better at making videos,
doing parties, doing graduation,
and get to the point where you can sustain yourself
100% financially with your videography editing business.
You know, or common theme,
maybe just completely leave the food industry
and start working at a job that is going to really help you
get better at the video editing.
We're kind of on a roll here.
Why not get all the skills that you need
and, you know, get a job that can help you get those skills?
So I think it's exciting for someone at 47 years old
to all the sudden realize your dream,
realize your passion and decide, I actually want to do this.
Like, why not, you know, why not go and do it?
And it obviously is something that's really exciting
for you and start by telling all your friends,
I want to film your parties or your graduations
and you know, you can grow along the way.
And I think it's exciting.
What do you think, Ed?
Yeah, Jamil, one, I think it's great
to want to honor your father
and I'm sure there's a lot of familiar connection
and you feel close to him by being in the business
and that can be a lot to give up.
You know, at some point you do have to decide
whether it's going to be your life or your father's life,
right, like that was his business.
Do you want to make it yours or not, right?
Like he's past, you know, you get to do what you want to do
and it's never too late to take action on it.
So that's a start.
I'm in the middle of trying to fight someone here
so this is a stressful situation.
Who are you today, by the way?
I'm Timo Jungle, I've got my go-to strategy, Timo Jungle.
Yeah, so I would see how much do you like the business
right now or not?
Do you want to keep going at all?
Does the thought of getting up in the morning
and doing this just petrify you, you hate it,
you don't want to do it at all?
If that's the case, then I'd be looking at,
okay, how can I sell the business
and move on to something else?
He has a business right now, right?
I'm not sure, he didn't actually mention
if they had a business, it was just,
I guess his father was, you know,
they work in the food sector.
Okay, so you mean he's in the business.
Okay, well, whether it is his business or not,
in general, if you are an entrepreneur
and you've lost the love for your business,
then I'd be looking at,
okay, how can I sell this?
Because it's never going to be higher value.
Because if you've lost the passion for it,
moving on to something else,
when you've checked out mentally the value,
people think they can coast and it's like,
oh, you know, keep making this amount per year
and it won't, it'll start going down,
you'll stop caring.
So the time to get the most amount of dollars out of it
is right now.
And it also frees up your emotional energy
to move on to go out and do something else.
If it's just in terms of jobs,
then I agree with Rishy in that I'd be looking at,
hey, can I find a job where I can learn more?
It also depends on your kind of financial situation.
You know, if you're starting from the bottom
in the video editing business,
that may not be feasible at the moment.
But making sure that you're spending time every day
on this business.
Telling your friends, volunteering, getting better,
interning at video production companies,
researching different techniques, practicing on your own.
Maybe there's a model to combine it.
If you know the food industry super well,
can you combine it, video editing with the food business?
All restaurants need videos
and every business should have videos
to talk about their business.
So can you be that guy?
That's great.
Right, does that, video production
serves a lot of different industries.
Do you care what industry you're serving in?
I know he mentioned kids, parties and stuff.
Is that like what really makes you come alive
or does it matter?
Because you can probably apply your knowledge
of the food industry business to go out and get clients
for the video production side
because you understand how to make and sell food.
So that gives you a really big advantage
over other video production companies.
Even people who may have been around for a while
because you understand that industry.
So that may be your thin wedge in
to be able to get some sales and get some experience.
So those two things, like if you can afford it
to go and leave your, if it's a job,
to start off somewhere else where you can learn,
go out and do it.
If you can't yet, then you're doing it on the side
and trying to combine the interest and skill level
that you have to provide the best value to your clients
and in this case it'd probably be providing videos
for the food service business.
Love it.
I think it starts with the decision that this is my life.
I feel like he's already gotten there
but a lot of people haven't where they're doing something
because their parents, either the parents are still alive
and telling them, hey, you need to do this.
This is, you need to go do this job.
It's a family of lawyers so you need to be a lawyer too.
Or they've passed and you're just trying to honor,
you're trying to honor their memory, also common.
But at some point you need to decide whether this is,
again, your life or someone else's life.
Make that decision and from there it becomes easier.
Like once you've decided, everything becomes easier.
And once you've truly decided,
everything's becoming easier.
I'm being attacked, I'm being attacked.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
All right, all right.
I love that and sometimes like you said,
sometimes it's not just your family,
it's just maybe it's your friends or whoever it is
that you feel their expectations you need to live up to
and that can be easier said than done,
getting to the point where you just don't,
you're able to let go
of what other people's expectations are of you.
And like you said, when you finally make that last,
you kind of finally cut the cord
is when some really cool things can happen.
I also will say, I just remembered there's a new book out,
it's called, It's Never Too Late to Begin Again,
Discovering Creativity and Meaning at Midlife and Beyond
by Julia Cameron.
And I think that would be an awesome book to check out
because I think a lot of people think that
once you're in midlife or beyond like trying to start over,
it's just, it's too late, but it's not.
So hopefully that will be a helpful resource to you, Emil.
Yeah, there's a video we're putting up soon on the channel
with Quincy Jones, it's a Quincy Jones top 10.
And he got asked that question,
I really liked his answer, you guys should check it out.
But basically he was also saying that he's still learning,
like he hasn't figured it all out,
even as much as he has accomplished,
he still is not the know-all of everything.
Did I get a kill?
Yes, haha, happy about that.
So yeah, when you see the Quincy Jones video come out,
I'd recommend checking that one out too.
Great.
And just one last thought on the like
other people's expectations, it's not that you don't care.
Like if your mom wants you to do something
and you don't want to do it,
it's not that you don't care about it, right?
I think that's what sometimes people say,
like hey, don't care about what other people say.
Like it obviously will still impact you
if your mom hates what you're doing.
But it's that you're making the conscious choice
that this is your life and you need to live it.
And your own opinion of yourself
is more important than anybody else's.
So it's not that you don't care,
it's just you put yourself first
above other people and their expectations.
So yeah, it's still going to hurt,
it's still not necessarily an easy decision,
but the more you get used to doing it,
the easier it does become.
Thanks.
Great, it reminds me of that hangout you just did,
which was really, really interesting.
Choose yourself.
Oh, James Altucher.
Yeah, yeah, I found that to be a fascinating interview
and actually in that interview also,
you guys talked about how more and more people
are changing careers.
Like it's now no longer a rare thing
for people to just change careers multiple times.
So you're in good company, Jamil.
Love it.
All right, next question comes from Vivek.
Vivek.
Vivek, love it.
Vivek has an educational startup
and what they do is they provide summer,
winter training programs for graduate engineers.
And he has a few questions for you, three actually.
And the first question is, what percent of your profit
of your business should be saved for profit
or should be reinvested into the company?
Let's just take that question first.
You know, I think this is a great question, Evan,
because I think that isn't every business, you know,
it's like every business is led by a person
or at least starts with a person
and that person comes with their own set
of money management, belief, rules, thoughts
and so whatever that entrepreneur practices
in terms of money management
will greatly affect their business.
So I think that how you answer this question
in terms of what percent you save for profit
and for the business, I think it's gonna be variable.
I can't wait to hear what you have to say, Evan,
but I would assume there are a few things
you would wanna be thinking about
because I don't know that there's just a fixed percentage
that's gonna work across the board for every entrepreneur.
But I'd be asking questions like, you know,
what are your current commitments financially
just to keep the business going right now?
You know, what are those commitments?
Because I think those are gonna vary again
across the board, person to person, business to business.
And then also thinking about your future growth,
you know, what commitments are gonna come
with the expansion of your business?
Because as your business grows, then you may need more,
you know, you may need to hire people,
you may need to rent out space.
There are all these things that are gonna come up
with your growth that you, I think, wanna be considering
when you're thinking about saving or reinvesting.
So I think it's just a good point to have a good plan
not just for today but like for your future of your business
because I think those questions of how much you save,
what you do with the money is gonna be largely determined
by how well you're kind of able to be
where you envision your business going.
All right, over to me.
On to you, sir.
All right, so it depends on one, your phase of growth
and also on your financial situation.
It is super common for early stage businesses
to lose money because you're growing.
Like high growth companies typically lose money
because you're investing so much into where you can go.
Now, not everybody can necessarily afford that, right?
If you are reliant on that income to feed your family
and pay your bills and all that stuff,
then you may not be able to take all that investment
and put it back in your company.
You may need to take a little bit more off the table
and hold it back for yourself.
So there's no one rule.
You know, it's nice to have a fixed, easy answer
and for me to say, 20%, put it back in.
But you know, in the early stages of your business,
you won't even have profit.
I think he was asking profit, right?
Not revenue, right?
What percentage of your profit, right?
Oh, we got a kill, all right.
Yeah, so it really depends on
where you see the business growing,
how quickly you see it growing.
Companies have to make these decisions on a big scale.
Even more mature companies have to decide
how much dividend do we give to our customers, right?
Because if they see a lot of growth
in investments that they can make,
then they should not be given more dividends.
But if they, can we get a kill?
Yes.
Good job, sounds like you're going.
I'm okay, but the team is losing so far.
But it's close, it's close.
People criticize Apple.
Apple should have a higher,
Apple has all this cash on hand.
They should have a higher dividend.
Give cash back to the investors.
But if you see that you have a lot of opportunity
to invest back in,
where do you see your business going?
Do you see a ton of growth from a certain market
that you need to save up and put towards the business?
Then you need to save up and do that.
It's in the best interest of the company.
If you don't know where you're gonna spend the money,
then it doesn't make sense
to just randomly invest in things.
And so when you see companies investing,
increasing their dividend rate,
it's typically because they haven't figured out
where else they're gonna spend the money,
so we might as well give it back to investors.
So you may not be at that point
where you have investors and dividends and all that,
but the point of that story is there's no one fixed answer.
It really depends on,
do you see a lot of growth potential in your business?
Is there a lot of different places that you can invest?
Or are you just doing what you're doing
and there's no growth opportunities?
And then two, how badly do you need the money?
It's great to say, yeah, take 50% of profits
and save it for future investment into the business.
But if you have a mortgage bill coming up
that you have to pay,
that's not gonna really help you.
So, but be confident that there's no,
it may slow down your growth
if you're taking money off the table now
because you need it,
but it doesn't make it wrong too.
You can still have a massively successful business
if you're just slowing down your rate of growth.
And it forces you to be a little more strategic
with where you do spend the money,
or you spend it on things
that will make the biggest impact on your company.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I liked when I was hearing your thoughts too on,
for example, hiring.
I think you were talking about how,
if you do get to the stage where you can have,
you can reinvest by actually hiring someone.
Hiring someone who maybe an hour of their time
will give you,
raise you up to have hours.
It's like it was a profitable investment
more than maybe putting the money somewhere else
because hiring that one person
made you way more money than if you had done it elsewhere.
So there's some great videos I know
I've seen on your channel, Evan,
about the hiring process that could be thought of
as like a way of reinvesting smart into your business
so that you're making more money than if you didn't.
Absolutely.
Say you wanna pull money off the table
to be able to do something in your personal life,
well, maybe investing into hiring somebody new on your team
gives you the personal time off
to be able to go and do whatever you wanna do
or take care of those resources by investing time and not,
oh, okay.
Good, good, good.
We're doing damage.
Yeah, so it doesn't mean you have to pull money
off the table for yourself.
It might be that you hire somebody
and that frees up your time
that then you can spend your time going off
and doing whatever you need to on a personal level.
So in all likelihood,
especially at the start of a business,
there's no rule of thumb
because the variables are changing so often
and your personal situation is changing so often
that you're not some multi-billion dollar company
that you have predictability in what's gonna go on.
And so don't worry about it.
You can have a goal,
but if you see a high-growth company,
then you wanna invest.
If you see a lot of opportunity in your business,
you wanna invest as much as possible,
100% back into your business to see it grow
because that's gonna pay long-term dividends.
So you wanna invest as much as you can afford
if you see a lot of potential,
but don't feel bad if you can't
because hey, you need to earn a living too.
You need to be able to feed yourself
because all that future growth won't mean anything
if you're not around to see it.
So that's the balance.
Great.
He has a second question about marketing.
Okay.
And he's asking for, again,
his business as a startup to train graduate engineers.
And he's kind of wondering what are different ways
that he could market for a training program.
And I would just say
there's so many ways that you could market.
Obviously, I would ask,
do you really know where your audience,
your target market, where are they?
Where are the people that you wanna attract?
And it could be anything from putting
flyers up at a graduate school
and trying to get those recent grads
to know right away that they can come to you,
to social media, to getting people on an email list.
There's just tons and tons of ways to market.
But I think the question I'd be asking is
where are the people that you're trying to target?
Where are they hanging out most?
And go there.
Yeah, my favorite way is through alliances.
So I'd be looking at who is already selling to engineers,
where are engineers already hanging out,
and how can you find a way to partner up with them
so that they can introduce,
got another kill, super happy.
I got four kills and one assist with no deaths.
So this is a rocking game show.
But belief team is doing well today.
Almost.
Yeah, so where are these engineers hanging out?
I got another kill.
Where are the engineers hanging out?
What are they doing?
What groups are they a part of?
Who else are they buying from?
Can you connect with career, the crew counselors?
Or is there an engineering club?
Where are these guys hanging out?
And then how can you basically be on the radar
to those people and find a way to be able to work together?
That's gonna be your fastest way
in to be able to reach those engineers.
Okay.
And final question from Vivek is
what would I not wanna do with this type of startup?
So a big, huge general question, what not to do.
And I would just say, you know, don't give up.
If this is what you really wanna do,
if this is something that you're super passionate about,
go for it.
Don't let any fear hold you back
from just really going after it.
Going after, you're going after it.
I love it.
I had a much, I had a practical answer.
Not that yours isn't, but I like yours better.
Honestly, if you're giving general advice to a startup,
you know, most important is one,
you're doing something that you love.
So don't chase engineers
because you think it's just a way to make a lot of money.
You gotta have a strong why
as to why you wanna help out engineers
and why you're starting this business,
which we didn't really address,
but I guess we just did now.
And then persistence, right?
Like if it's that important to you,
then when it doesn't work out,
when those first alliance partners don't work,
when your first speaking gig flops,
when all the things go wrong,
you stick with it, you keep doing it.
Oh, my team got dragged and I wasn't there, interesting.
I'm not paying enough attention
to what's going on on the map.
Yeah, so like reach this point of not giving up,
super important, entrepreneurs usually give up too soon.
They give up just as they're starting to get some momentum
and it takes a while to build momentum.
I think that's the thing is people think it's gonna take
a lot less time than it actually does
and so they get frustrated and they quit too soon.
So, I love that, super important.
The one that immediately came to mind
was don't spend money until you're making money.
Oh, that's good.
It's easy to go out and spend a ton of money on stuff.
Like hey, well to get this business off the ground,
I need to whatever, right?
I need to get a website, I need to get business cards,
I need to get flyers, I need to hire the best speakers
and it's easy to go out and spend a ton of money on stuff.
But it's hard to actually go out and make the money.
Anybody can spend the money and I would just encourage you
to invest your heart, your hustle, your drive,
your energy to go pull in business
and then once you start making a little bit of money,
you can do a little, some small bets.
So you can, if you wanna try flyers, then try flyers
but don't spend $20,000 on flyers, spend 500, right?
And see if that works for you.
And if it does, you can keep going and if not,
then you find another alternative.
I think entrepreneurs just typically spend way too much,
way too soon and it really hurts them.
That's good, really good, especially for startups,
any startup.
Okay, well, you guys, thanks for the question.
Moving on to Charles.
And Charles has a Facebook page
and he wanted some feedback on his Facebook page.
He's a part of an organization called Jacob Ministries
and just a little bit about it,
I know Evan, you can't see the Facebook page.
I took a little, I took a glance at it
to give you an idea of what was on the Facebook page.
It was, it's a religious organization
and it says we are a funding corporation.
Our goal is to bring additional funds
to any organization that needs it.
Local outreach to schools, churches, community buildings
and in the feed of the Facebook page,
I just, he basically had,
it looks like he could be a YouTuber
because I saw some videos up that just had some.
We haven't had a YouTube reishi answer yet.
I'm excited for this.
I know, I know.
Well, yeah, so he had some videos up
that were just kind of like positive,
very encouraging messages that he was sharing.
So maybe we can give him some feedback just in general
how to make a good, either business Facebook page
or page for your organization
that will really attract the people that you want to attract.
All right, well, we just won the game,
so that's a good start.
Wow.
Yeah, it was fast.
I went, I had six kills, no deaths and three assists.
Pretty excited about that.
Cool, okay, so he has a Facebook page
trying to raise money for religious organizations
to try to help,
like he wants to help other people raise money
or he wants to raise money himself?
It sounds like he wants to help other people
with their funding.
Okay, got it.
And how does he do that through a Facebook page?
That's his question?
Yeah, he wanted your feedback in general
just about what do you think of this Facebook page
and any tips or advice.
Okay.
I know when I looked at the page,
it wasn't super clear to me.
Well, first of all, it's great.
It's cool to see anyone who wants to do something
that is just gonna help other people get their needs met.
So, you know, hats off to you for you having a passion
to want to just help other people in their goals.
And it just wasn't,
when I was looking at the Facebook page,
it wasn't super clear right off the bat what exactly,
I know that when I went to the about section,
I was able to see that you want to do funding
for different, you know, these different schools,
churches, and communities groups,
but I wasn't really sure how, you know,
it just wasn't super clear exactly beyond
reading your about section what it is that you do.
So I think the first thing I would just say
for any Facebook page,
whether it's a business or an organization,
is just make it as easy as possible
for people to come to your page,
know exactly what you do and then how you do it,
how I can, you know, what is the value
that you're immediately giving to the people
that you're wanting to reach.
Only because the YouTube videos,
they were, it was cool to see encouraging videos,
but I wasn't sure how the YouTube videos
were at all connected with the about, you know,
there wasn't much information that I could see
off the bat about how if I was an organization
who needed funding, how you were going to help me
get from A to B.
So I think it was harder,
there might be ways that you can communicate
your message more effectively.
What do you think, Ed?
I think it's an interesting cause.
I think, you may agree,
if people are having a hard time understanding
what you do and they're clicking around to 1,000 pages,
they may not give you the chance to let you,
you know, prove yourself when they walk away confused.
I think to most charitable organizations
do a terrible job of storytelling
and fundraising is storytelling, that's what it is.
Like you need to tell me your story.
It sounds like one, you're not doing a good job
of telling your own story because, you know,
Rishy goes to the page and doesn't understand
what you're doing, so you need to improve
your own storytelling, but then also learn
how to tell the stories of these organizations
that you're working with.
I don't know if I didn't get if this is like
a business for him or he just wants to help out
and contribute back to his community.
Either way, if you can tell their stories better
than they can tell their stories
or help them tell their stories
or help pull out key messages,
then that's gonna be the key way in.
Because I think everybody wants to contribute back
in some way, I think if, you know, every year,
you know, a lot of us, you know,
I've given to a lot of different causes,
whether, you know, you guys listening,
I'm sure over the past year you've given
to at least one cause, whether it's Girl Guide Cookies
or, you know, Cancer Fundraiser or your friend
is biking in the race or something,
and you pledged some money to help them.
People want to help, there's just so many causes, right?
Like, why should I do yours instead of helping
feed kids in Africa, you know, or whatever,
like there's tons of causes, even within
the religious community, like if you're picking people
who you say, okay, well I only want to contribute
to religious organizations, great.
There's still tons of options within
the religious community, why should I pay,
you know, to support whatever organization
is on your website instead of just giving more
to my church, you know, like I love my pastor
and I'm going to pay him a lot more money
because he's, you know, giving me messages every week
that move me, why should I go and pay you money for it,
right, and so that's where the story becomes
super important, and I think if I was, you know,
Facebook is a great, a great starting point,
I think it's obviously so community-driven,
you don't need a lot of technical skills
to be able to have success on Facebook, which is great,
and if you don't know how to make a website,
Facebook is a great place to start for everybody out there,
but I think the most important thing for you,
that skill to learn is storytelling,
first your own, why it's so important,
and then the causes that really mean something to you,
finding their stories in a way that,
like use yourself as a barometer,
you've picked these organizations for a reason, why,
and when you are helping tell their stories,
it's something that moves you,
just as a quick example, at Toronto Dance Salsa,
we have a TV, it's a retail store,
and we have a TV at the front,
and I wanted to have random acts of kindness
showing on that TV 24-7, not about our,
so it's not our schedule, it's not how much our classes are,
it's not about our school,
I want random acts of kindness,
and then underneath it says, go help somebody today,
Toronto Dance Salsa, or something like that.
I love it.
And the idea was I want people to have an emotional reaction
walking by my shop, and it's great,
people walk by and they stop, and they look at it,
and some people cry, and it makes people think,
which is great, but I made that video myself,
I picked the videos that went up on that TV,
and they were all ones that choked me up,
that when I watched them on silent mode,
because we can't have volume,
so I watched hundreds of YouTube videos on silent mode
to find the ones that choked me up,
that I felt like I wanted to go do something positive
and good in the world after watching it,
and that's what I put up on the TV.
And so, use yourself as a barometer
when you're trying to tell the story of a local church
or whatever organization you're trying to help out,
the story needs to choke you up,
needs to make you want to donate money to this cause
because it's so powerful.
So, those two things.
Learn storytelling better,
learn how to apply it to your own business,
learn how to then apply it to other organizations,
there's lots of different resources
on how to learn how to tell stories better,
and then use yourself as a barometer
so that when something motivates and inspires you,
understand that that is likely going to have an impact
and motivate and inspire others as well.
Great, wow, that's great, great.
That's it?
Yeah. Love it.
Cool, well, another successful session.
I think my win rate when I'm on with you
is like 90% or something.
I seem to always win when we do that,
which looks great,
because a lot of people who stream
and then save videos to YouTube,
they only pick the ones where they win, right?
It's like, oh, I just dominated with Teemo or whatever,
and they post those victories,
but when they get stomped and lose, they don't post them.
I've never seen you, you're right.
I kind of was like this League of Legends game.
I've never seen Evan lose at it, so what's up with it?
It's definitely a Rishy Cup influence,
because I'm not, they have these ranking systems
where you go from bronze to silver to gold,
and you keep working way up,
and I'm stuck in silver, which is probably about average,
but I haven't, the way you get above it is by winning,
so I keep winning when we're doing this together,
but it means I'm losing when we're not.
I feel like I lost one game.
I feel like of all the episodes we've done,
I lost one game.
I don't remember you ever losing.
Seriously, I really don't.
I'm intrigued.
I'm going to go back and look and see.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure there's one,
but anyway, this is good.
This is good karma, helping out entrepreneurs.
Cup of win.
Well, thank you guys for watching.
Thank you, Rishy, for joining in again,
spreading some love.
Keep the questions coming in.
Continue to believe, and we'll see you soon.